en jarquín las tareas cotidianas se han
convertido en actividades de alto riesgo
natalia kolesnik salió con una vecina
alimentar a los gatos del barrio y
ninguna volvió tuvieron la mala suerte
de cruzarse con un bombardeo ruso
como ella muchos otros civiles han
muerto en la ciudad se olvidó de llevar
el teléfono con ella fue alimentar a los
gatos mi hermana llamó y dijo mamá no
está en casa me preguntó si estaba
conmigo le dije que no y salí corriendo
mi padre ya estaba aquí fue cuando
comprendí que era ella aquí los vecinos
han visto mucho sufrimiento y no
entienden por qué los rusos siguen
bombardeando zonas residenciales
y este transporte todas las noches nos
despertamos diez veces y esperamos a que
empiecen a bombardear lo que hacen estos
bárbaros
aquí hay edificios y residenciales por
qué y aquí no hay nada más
moscú sigue negando este tipo de ataques
a civiles en ucrania sin embargo si está
intensificando nuevamente sus embestidas
en el norte de jarquín la segunda ciudad
más grande del país y una de las más
resistentes desde el inicio de la guerra
en paralelo a los ataques a los
edificios residenciales las tropas rusas
también bombardearon y causaron
destrozos en una escuela aunque no se
registró ningún herido
pekín chino producción no se creo que es
así como se destruye una nación para que
nuestros hijos dejen de existir para que
nosotros dejemos de existir y de enseñar
duros golpes para la ciudad y sus
habitantes que luchan por su
reconstrucción tras la devastación
causada por la guerra